テキストも全部英語だもんね
英語とフランス語もちょっと違うから
色とかも白がホワイトじゃないし
ブランス
イメージがもう頭の中ぐちゃぐちゃになりますよね
そうね
何だろう
何でダウンとは考えないんですよ
考えて訳してると大変だから
白をしろってまず思って
それからホワイトって言ったらダメだけど
それからポッとホワイトって思えるようになれば
もうそれで
フランス語でもそうよね
フランス語でもやってらっしゃるんでしょ
やってないです全然
何十年前だっけ
何も知らないで行って
三十年前の話だって
私も電車の中で教えてくれたりするんだよね
発音が違う
アルルでおられる
アルルって言ったらノーノーノー
アルルかって言って
アルルが言えるまで何回も罰が
日本にない発音なんで
アルルルって言えるまで
だいぶ教えてもらいました
周りの人たち
日本人は割とみんなどうせ日本語なんか知らないだろうからって
心切にゆっくりねしゃべったりする時
向こうの人ってバーっとこうしゃべってきて
そうね分かる方が当然そうですよね
面白かったです
道聞かれた時びっくりしましたね
全然知らない僕に聞かないでほしい
フランス語で
初めてのとこへ来て道を聞かれても
もっと聞く人は隣にいるように
そういうアンマークベットの
いろんな人がいるから分かんないみたい
そういう感覚があんまりないみたい
日本だとね日本人がほぼ日本人って分かるから
外国のちょっと違うから言われたら
外国人だなと思って丁寧にできるけど
フランスにしても人種の留守というか
黒人もいるし
黄色人もいっぱいいるから
誰でもこの人でもフランス人にいたのかもしれないなって
いろんな人がいる中でなんで僕が聞くんだよ